[Musique]
un ou deux mois quand tu écris de vienne
à dire une histoire incroyable une
démarche d'une attaque à multiples mais
celle de la pendule
c'est bientôt fini encore deux minutes
et margot vais terminer quel art et il
fait beau possible de commencer ma
portée à 7 regarde y'a d'eau mis en
cause au travail en comble et allait
arrêter ses bienfaits elle dort
l'apartheid dont elle a réveillé la
mettre à l'heure je suis fait moins âgée
fait c'est peut être l'heure de mon
repas mosca les havrais la grande yaka
ce que j'ai fait alors qu'elle aurait
dit un instant crois que je vais
consulter la fraude hull
c'est ça peut vite évoluer rapidement
cette pendule et à l'autre extrémité du
palais parce que le grand yaka ne
supporte pas sauter kita que la porte
est ouverte à quelques négligences le
moindre courant d'air peu l'anru mais si
fragile une pendule payant quelle heure
et il le leur et qui a parlé
je ne me trompe pas je ne rêve pas la
pro du parlant la pendule a parlé auquel
faire alors mostar quelle heure est il
il est 7h30 quand reviendras tu as mais
bien sûr quand il ya quinze jours suis
certain c'est elle même qui me l'a dit
commun n'a pas dû lui a parlé
elle m'a parlé je vous parle homo ce cas
mais tu es malade
la pendule ne parle pas et ça démarre ça
dépend combien cas si la première fois
mais elle a parlé aux jeunes dames mais
je veux que tu ne me donnes moi je vis
ici dit kodiak
je vais la poussée jusqu ici reste en
ouvrant le double non au moins moi entre
ados ont ce très pratique cette pendule
parlant d' excellente idée
c'est très moderne ses deux enfants
[Musique]
audrey est ce possible que si elle
marche elle marche alors c'était pas du
camp diable
il e marche et mais j'espère bien
qu'elle marche et le marché depuis de
césar c'est son travail alors je veux la
voir les impôts si la rafle la poisse y
aura grand kaka et au mosca mosquée mais
je rêve je le vous le marché amm au ska
et le domaine de colombe ibérique
ouvrez vos yeux voila voila grande yaka
[Musique]
je loue un voilà elle est ouverte on
chez toi qui tu che alors m'ont pas fait
et a vu le droit de connaître l'heure
alors auront curieuse façon assez titi
sa raquette est astucieux il a fait
marcher la pendule et jusqu'ici mais ça
alors c'est très adroit vie ouais c'est
très têtu tu m'as mènera la pendule
comme ça chaque fois que je te
demanderai le riz et moi et qu'on veut
encore vu devenu long pendule et après
après fait nos trucs toi
[Musique]